YOU KNOW, I'D SAY
MY FAVORITE ASPECT OF SCIENCE
IS THE PROCESS.
YOU HAVE A HYPOTHESIS
ABOUT MAYBE HOW THE WORLD WORKS
OR WHAT'S GOING ON
AND THEN YOU GO OUT,
AND YOU TEST IT.
THE THING I LIKE MOST
ABOUT SCIENCE
IS THAT EVERY DAY,
I START WITH
A CLEAN SHEET OF PAPER.
AND EVERY DAY,
I HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CREATE
A WHOLE BODY OF KNOWLEDGE
THAT NEVER EXISTED BEFORE.
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT SCIENCE
IS THAT IT FASCINATES ME
THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO UNDERSTAND THE UNIVERSE
TO ANY DEGREE AT ALL.
WHY THE SKY IS BLUE,
WHAT MAKES RAINBOWS HAPPEN,
HOW EARTH SCIENCE WORKS,
WHAT DO VOLCANOES COME FROM --
IT'S AN AMAZING THING.
EVERYTHING IS IN THERE,
AND WE'RE SURROUNDED BY IT.
AND WE JUST HAVE TO LEARN
HOW TO STUDY IT
SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND IT.
AND WE TRY TO USE THOSE ANSWERS
TO MAKE OUR LIFE A LOT EASIER.
I LOVE HOW SCIENCE
IS ABLE TO EXPLAIN
THE MYSTERIES OF THE WORLD
TO ANYBODY.
SCIENCE TALKS TO KIDS.
IT TALKS TO ADULTS.
AND IT JUST EXPLAINS THIS
WONDERFUL PLACE WE LIVE IN.